oh boy
well hello i heard you guys were making
the rounds again
all right this one's all you tiger come
on
police hey ma'am
thank you guys here hold this the
lasagna's burning
okay um get the dog but don't let it
touch the baby
[Music]
peralta yo i looked at the photos of
your victim on your desk
is that frozen don't worry i said hi
puncture wounds are similar to a case i
had a while back
they aren't from a knife i think it's
something spiral like a corkscrew
don't shush me i'm helping you no no i'm
holding a baby that was actually very
helpful thank you
oh you better get back here now
oh hello peralta
oh no no no i know why you're so upset
man i'm the one who had to come to this
backwater stink hole
what's up little man what's up you
feeling sexy huh
yeah i feel sexy and you look sexy you
know i do watch out for that door
yo how much you bench seriously ooh
brownies
i'm taking two so i can parcel them up
and eat them
at my leisure later on much healthier
you're taking two
yeah um but one of them is for tubby
yeah
why don't you send that to him in costa
rica um i'm just gonna
hand it to him right now okay weirdo why
is that why is that weird
she said she was gonna give it to him
right now she's probably going to
because they sit next to each other yeah
they used to
toby works here again oh can you imagine
oh no oh you don't know i don't know
what you should probably just meander
back there
take a look see if he's see if he's back
dare i
you know what i'm going to for old
time's sake
great practical joke jim can we go to
the annex
no god no
god please no no no
no hello raymond
captain wunch good to see you but if
you're here
who's guarding hades it's deputy chief
watch now
unsurprisingly i've been promoted above
you and now i'm here to evaluate you
what happened to brandt he retired and
moved to charleston to be closer to his
grandchildren
so much for dying at your desk with a
little dignity interesting
i will attempt to cooperate with you
under these
new circumstances don't sweet talk me
halt
i gave it my best shot let's
begin and since my arrival
violent crime has gone down by 17.3
as you can see here two-toned graphs
you think you can distract me from this
precinct's problems with a flashy
presentation
same old ray halt false sizzle no steak
i'm off to do some spot checks
oh my god she's totally gonna flunk us i
haven't gotten enough since i failed
recess in second grade
teachers need a break too amy we were
doomed the minute she slithered into the
precinct
it's funny when we first met we had some
good times
[Music]
looks like we both want that stapler
seems that way based on what happened
so when did it all go south 1989.
i was up for a big promotion which would
have fast-tracked my career
watch offered to write a letter on my
behalf but instead she torpedoed me
because
of something that happened the night
before she was to turn it in
madeleine
would you care for a drink i'd love one
i'm sure you can tell i'm quite drunk
i've had a couple to build up the nerve
i think we both
know what i'm about to say raymond
i don't think we need to say anything
i'm gay that's what i was going to tell
you
well then she sabotaged my career
because i refused to
bed her nothing good will come
wait
she's here isn't she
hi ron
tammy good
good start i'm sorry about this but i
just
really want to talk to you couldn't we
go have a cup of coffee
let's get this over with thanks ron
it means a lot you're a miracle worker
do you know what you just did yes donna
i got two people to put aside years of
hostility and open a door to the
possibility of friendship
you were not here when ron and tammy got
divorced i was those two are
crazy yeah and you just opened the gates
to crazy town frankly i think ron was
acting like a baby
a little bit i mean what is he afraid of
tammy's just a woman a nice woman
you know she's not a murderer she's not
a dragon
it's really good to see you ron
you've aged horribly you
son of a [__] oh my god
what is your problem nothing's changed
has it
he set the bed on fire excuse me i did
okay is that what you wanted
we're fine we're fine please take it
outside
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so
rewarding
oh yes baby got it
what's going on um somebody vomited
right in the middle of the carpet in my
office
i don't think that's vomit check it out
me
check it out
be a wuss just get known holding your
coffee
tell me what it is oh that's really good
what is it
michael what is it no just tell me what
it is michael i
i gotta get out of here i can't hold my
breath that long
open the door up it smelled terrible
oh i cannot believe a pipe burst and
left that there there's no burst pipe
how do you know that what is it then hey
guys somebody making soup
yes hello yes i'm looking for a gay
nerd named michael scott who is this how
did you get this number
your mom you gay nerd oh my god
hacker paxter wacky pack how you doing
hey listen did you get that package i
left for you
uh no did anybody see a package here
today
no how big was it it was pretty big
really
you see a big package where did you
leave it
in the middle of your office really guys
did you see a big package in my office
you mean the thing
are you kidding me
that was packer oh you're i you are dead
you are dead my friend that is hilario
oh god of course it was you
yeah yeah oh
my god it was packer i miss you i miss
you too
where are you i'm in my new city council
office no way
i know do you like it i love it i love
it too check this out
here is my wall of inspirational women
ah is that a picture of you yes i am big
enough to admit that i am often inspired
by myself
here are my clocks pawnee and washington
dc same
time zone oh this is the coolest part
ever i have my own private bathroom
occupy oh my god
councilman jam what are you doing in my
bathroom i don't know if i would call it
your bathroom its only door is in my
office
i think it is crazy that the most junior
city councilor gets a private bathroom
just because she is a girl excuse me
let's solve this
tell you what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
drop my liquids in here
take my solids down the hall deal no
no deal fine your loss
how
you